all right it's not going to be 10 or 15
years by all appearances of deshaun
watson in houston an update based upon
today's developments cal mcnair
says that he has spoken to deshaun
watson which is good because as of a
week ago desean watson would not talk to
cal mcnair the owner of the team that's
never a good sign mcnair has spoken to
deshaun watson and he wants watson in
the loop for the coaching hire
the question is is it too little too
late after they cut him out of the loop
for the gm hire and they refused
to interview the guy that he wanted the
team to hire to be the head coach eric b
enemy the chiefs offensive coordinator
and how about the tweet
from deshaun watson today shireen that i
think
confirms
that none of this has changed none of it
matters it's too little too late i was
on two then i took it to ten now the
naysayers are saying it's just song
lyrics well yeah it's also the exact
phrase that adam schefter used last
weekend on espn to characterize watson's
mindset
after he wasn't consulted before they
made nick casario the gm that's not an
accident and that's the context that
these things are being said and this
isn't just some random i feel like
tweeting out song lyrics he's smart
enough to know that there's a broader
background for whatever he says and
anything he says is going to be
scrutinized just like last week when he
tweeted some things never changed and
then he deleted it
i was on two now i'm on 10
confirms what schefter said and it tells
me that this clumsy effort by the texans
this week shireen to repair the
relationship with deshaun watson has not
worked
and on top of that mike it came out
shortly after
john mcclane our friend at the houston
chronicle released his story basically
saying that cal mcnair is not going to
fire jack easterbee so it is not a
coincidence that he used the same
phrasing that adam shepard did over the
weekend or when the tweet was posted
there's no coincidence in that he's
still mad he's going to remain mad and
now cal mcnair said he's going to be
part of the coaching search they better
make him part of the coaching search
because they promised him that in the gm
search and then didn't do it they didn't
take his recommendations they didn't
take his advice they didn't consult him
like they said it would it would have
been a completely different thing if
they had taken what he said interviewed
those candidates and then said hey we're
hiring someone else but they obviously
didn't do that mike and so here they sit
with a problem with desean watson
houston had another problem in the nba
with in a similar situation and what did
james harden do he showed up overweight
out of shape started ripping his
teammates and they had to trade him just
to get rid of him and you can so see
this same scenario playing out in
houston so good luck nick casario and
making this thing work with deshaun
watson and you better make it work with
deshaun watson or this is a franchise
that's going to be
in a long rebuilding process
and
i think that desean watson unlike james
harden desean watson just won't show up
he'll make it clear i'm done it's over
he's not the kind of guy in my
assessment to make idle threats he's
very straightforward he's very direct
and once you've lost him you've lost him
for good their only hope of turning this
around is to hire eric the enemy and
have the enemy tell watson my first
order of business is to stuff jack
easter be in a locker and leave him
there that's the only way they're fixing
this
yeah i agree with you
it doesn't seem there's another out and
so you ask desean watson what he needs
to be happy there and that's what you
have to do frankly if you want to keep
deshawn watson and it looks like mike
it's going to come down to deshaun
watson or jack easterbee and i cannot
believe that calm and mcnair would pick
jack easterby i just can't even envision
that in in my thoughts but if that's the
way they go
wow this is an organization that's
that's really really in a lot of trouble
over the coming x number of years
because no one's going to want to go
there
i vaguely recall saying at some point
over the past week or so that if it came
down to deshaun watson or jack easterby
everyone in their right mind would pick
watson except for members of jack
easterby's family and at least half of
them would say watson as well so it is a
no-brainer i don't understand the spell
that easter bee has cast on mcnair and
this may be very simple shireen i mean
let's think about it cal mcnair owns
that team for one reason and one reason
only he's the son of the man who founded
it that's it he hasn't earned it he
hasn't worked for the money he hasn't
done anything to merit owning an nfl
team he just happened to be in the
lineage it's like royalty that's one of
the things that is fascinating about the
nfl we've got this complex football
structure that is driven by x's and o's
and analytics and all of these things
relevant to what happens on a football
field and it's all presided over
by these various monarchies that just
hand the team from generation to
generation well you know what sooner or
later and in some cases sooner you're
going to hand it to a generation that
doesn't know what the hell to do and cal
mcnair in my assessment with all due
discretion and respect and aware of the
potential consequences of making this
statement on peacock he doesn't know
what the hell to do
so he needs jack easterby to tell him
what to do well cal you don't have to
pay me three million dollars a year for
me to tell you what you need to do if
you want to turn this around and that's
to tell jack easter be bye bye or
completely neuter him to the point where
he has no way that he can have any
involvement over the football operation
although i think that's impossible the
only way to ensure that easter bee isn't
going to poison the relationship any
further than he has is to get him out of
there for good and until you do it
you're not going to get back to sean
watson
and you know what mike andre johnson was
supposedly on this committee that cal
mcnair put together and it looked like a
great committee and i would be
interested to hear what other committee
members think after being on this
committee that supposedly was going to
help this organization pick the right
people but andre johnson was on it and
when he saw his text
yeah it wasn't a committee that's the
thing it was reported as a committee it
was a bunch of different individuals
that cal mcnair spoke to one on one
that's a recipe for i'm going to keep
talking to all these different people
until someone tells me what i want to
hear that's not what a committee would
have done a committee works together
synthesizes comes up with the best
recommendation and makes one
recommendation and that's what the guy
better do if he wants the advice of the
committee this was i'm going to cast a
wide net of people i'll speak to and
somebody's going to tell me what i want
to hear and that's what i'm going to do
and you know what it was jack easterby's
the one who told him what he wanted to
hear
then that's exactly the way it worked
out jack used to be made that higher no
question about it but we saw andre
johnson's tweet so they have now
ostracized the best player in team
history the quarterback the franchise
quarterback you just gave a ton of money
to and who knows who else within the
organization they've ostracized so they
have a huge repair job here and i'm with
you i think it may be past the point of
return with deshaun watson and that's
what we're going to find out i think
over the coming weeks
yeah and i think the texans are going to
find out the hard way that they can't
fix this and they need to have a great
plan both for fixing it and for what do
we do if we can't fix it and the problem
is great plan is not a phrase that you
can use to
describe the texans in any way shape or
form
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports